what I'm sorry what I can't
hear Sam Rockwell is on the show
today welcome to the show someone's
about to walk out here who is literally
been my friend for numerous decades um
we have always believed in each other
it's amazing to see him doing so well in
his life in his personal life in his
career he has won an Oscar um yeah he
won an Academy
Award and I I love him so much we're
going to get into everything let's just
get him out here it's my dear friend the
one and only Sam
Rockwell oh
man
oh
man hey how you doing oh my
God so excited to see it oh my God my
leg went
[Applause]
up oh
God so excited to see you how about in
this context I know right this it's been
a minute this is not the Playboy Mansion
this is not the Playboy Mansion no CU
we've been there no that's right we have
been there oh the B things happened
there oh see I'm so happy to see you you
have no idea I'm so happy to see you
okay I don't even know where to begin
other than also I'm going to put a bunch
of cuz you texted me a bunch of pictures
we got all those in the Monitor and then
I'm going I sent her some pictures of of
us on with with uh on Confessions of a
dangerous mind directed by George
Clooney second movie yeah um well bring
those up they
are the backc of George's head you're
playing Chuck bars you me the real Chuck
Baris who was the host of The Gong Show
but there was look at you and George
look you know George told me that's 23
years ago um there's you and me and and
George doing a scene together don't we
look like such like close friends and
fpans we're really we really in the
bubble what the hell's going on there
that's just typical you and me you know
it's too bad you're not game for things
well that's us on a red carpet and it's
like of course we're dancing of course
we're dancing first of all Sam and I did
Charlie's Angels together um sh shakeing
big wait do you remember the audition
for that you remember what it was of
course I do it was the scene from fou
play so we did Chevy Chase and Goldie
Han we pulled Pages out of the old
script of Foul Play and read the scene
together and we have a boom box and we
did a little dance and stuff you're
always dancing you are Mr Capezio shoes
you
are Sam is the best dancer and if you
see Sam in a movie you will see Sam
dancing and of course an our guy there
go again you're dancing sorry about that
you're the best dancer remember when we
went clubbing in Montreal yeah yes I do
well no we had a lot of fun there was a
lot of interesting uh interesting stuff
there we and then of course yeah and
was the daisy duke was that your name
for at the Playboy we had we made up
names for ourselves to go to the Playboy
Mansion um you were you Demetrius
Fontaine yes I was Demetrius fonus Fon
Daisy Duke I
was no I don't think that was my name
wasn't Justin Long like Chuckles McGee
yeah that's right which is not a sexy
name at all but it won your heart I was
I loved okay I remember the night okay I
had broken up I was dating this guy who
was the classic like He's Just Not That
Into You guy like everything I did it
just I was all in and he wasn't so Sam
was like listen we're taking you for
drinks and I was like thank you so I
show up in my leather gloves I got all
dressed up cuz I wanted to feel good
about myself and I showed up for drinks
with you and Justin yeah and that's the
night I fell in love with Justin yeah
yeah we love Justin he's the best him he
comes on the show Kate comes on the show
they're the best couple they are best
couple oh they're so good for each other
they're a beautiful couple they're so
right for each other they are they are
they really they're really a great
couple yeah she's a sweetheart you and
lesie yes yes is it 17 years this year
it's about 17 years yeah
okay
lesle wow lesli's the one that really
like won your heart you know cuz you you
you had relationships but there nothing
like leslee yeah I was on a streak uh
when I met Leslie I think I was I was I
was trying to be single I was I was not
very good at it you did you liked being
single you you you you were I thought I
liked it and then I you know I thought I
had a little black book but it didn't
really work out I was too I'm too honest
and neurotic for is it true that even on
your first date with lesie like you had
a backup plan that's true you had like a
second date plan that's true and she
loves to remind me of that yeah how did
she even find out well she knew
instinctively cuz she said it was a day
date we were going to this Museum and I
was like really a day date yeah she said
she hadn't been drinking for a a while
and then she said let's go to ELC
Compadre and I was like oh are you sure
she's like yeah what the hell and so I
was like after the day date and I said
all right let me go get my cigarettes
and I got to tell my friend leaf that
I'm
oh I remember Leaf remember leaf and I
and she knew yeah that I had like a
backup date at like a nighttime you like
and in those days you probably had to
hit a pay phone or like something go
call the girl and be like I need an
excuse and lesle caught you she caught
me yeah she yeah but then we went and
got margaritas and salsa and chips well
I was on tequila the night with Justin
so we know where that leads yeah there
you go go lesie has been an amazing
actress an amazing comedian also which
love comedy helan nights yeah sure but
you know what else lesie bib just booked
is the third season of White Lotus
everybody that's
right yes I'm very proud of her she she
that's the most important franchise
right now period it is it is she's
working really hard on it too working
really hard on the script cheers cheers
to that cheers to Leslie cheers to
Leslie Bib and White
Lotus no she's working so hard on it
it's going to be it's going to be so
cool I'm really proud of her it's really
great I mean when I remember watching
her when you won the Academy Award and
it's like all of us who have known you I
think she hits me most of your
life we knew it was going to happen it
was a matter of when and you won yeah I
know it was for three billboards wild
stuff yeah pretty wild what did it feel
like it was it was kind of like you know
it's a big adrenaline rush and then you
you're up there and you're trying to get
off as quickly and gracefully as
possible yeah cuz they're like kind of
what it is they want you off quick they
want you off quick yeah you got a few
seconds to do it and then bang did you
like forget to say anything did you were
outter body was it like old school
blackout what just happened yeah totally
totally and I think I at the end I said
something about Phil but I didn't know
if they Phil Hoffman and I don't know if
they heard it Philip Hoffman was one of
Sam's best friends yeah and he was uh
he's kind of the best of us our
generation he was a he was a great actor